hey guys so Isaac is getting ready to
fly on his own for the very first time
ever are you nervous with it no no
excited you're excited he is officially
the first person heading towards the
wedding so he's on his way to Dallas
he's gonna go with Mama and yeah yeah
and he's gonna be there and then we
gotta go sorry mama and gay and he's
really good at the pronunciation I know
he's been teaching me cuz I know it's
hard for me to get the mama and the mama
cuz I guess it's two different ways
anyways yeah so he's gonna be heading
over to Dallas and then he's gonna fly
out from Dallas to Paris and we're gonna
meet him and Eddie oh my gosh the
wedding is happening already
I like how you match with your backpack
you packed it in a very sort of cool way
this what's that like a diaper yeah it
does so inside of it is underwear shirt
and in the middle there's these two
socks you had to wrap it around my shirt
so this [ __ ] can't stick out yeah I
found it on a hack online so like my
secret obsession is watching act videos
and I saw that on Twitter and I was like
oh I gotta try for Isaac's close to the
end and outfits of balls they would look
more like diapers like outfit diaper
shopping done do you wrap a diaper and
like that yeah I would know that
eventually years here - alright so we're
heading out uh daddy's gonna stay home
oh yeah by the way
Isaac's been calling KC daddy now I've
been working on it yeah now that we're
getting married he's like you know look
I think it's about time
he talked to me it was so sweet too
because his dad came over and all of us
were here in the living room and then he
asked permission his dad like oh can I
call Casey daddy his dad was like yeah
Horace he's an awesome dad so it's
pretty awesome that we all get along and
his dad was open to having Isaac call
Casey dad too that's good we're on the
same page he wished as well and the
wedding and everything anyways moving on
let's go to the airport we're at the
airport now are you nervous yeah
come on let's go oh you'll be talking to
strangers no no talking to James right
you don't take anything from any
stranger you know I've been talking to
him all right here try to tell me I'm
like okay make sure not says like
strangers don't take anything from
strangers I have this tag on you says
you're an unaccompanied minor you're
such a big boy
what are you doing right now eating
before light we are on our way to the
wedding there so we're all here ready to
signal / go to Paris we're gonna get
married
I am you are we are thank you
it's official yeah we're here are you
more excited now you know it's weird the
closer closer we're getting the less and
less anxious and nervous and I'm getting
really I'm the opposite I was like
chilling like what are we going for a
wedding okay yeah wedding yeah whatever
and then I'm like oh this happens to be
consistently whenever I'm like really
looking forward to something the further
away it is the the way more anxious and
excited I am but then the closer gets
the less and less I get it
and that much like the first time I went
skydiving I was like so like pumps and
like just do this but then once I
actually got in the plane and I was so
relaxed and so like then I'm so weird
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
so are we now Airbnb like we're here
good morning honey wait why are you down
here this isn't even the bed it's hard
he wanted a fortress it's like a little
protective wall how was everything all
the traveling traveling by yourself
really amazing would you like that did
you like a grown-up
missed you the other weird see meeting
up in Paris we're not in LA or not in
Dallas or in Paris that's so cool
this is my aunt or my cousin we'll stay
here probably oh they had their own
living room pretty much thank you
oh this is really cool I like the
exposed of wood if you want some privacy
taking a doodoo this is the rest room to
do it in that's gonna be fun I can't
wait Duty rest room right here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a French crepe a real one on the
side of the street fresh
yeah I want to buy you tease me with the
bike I was just about to take another
bite now you can have it you took it
back I was gonna show them when I just
said to you oh okay oh you're gonna
tease me again I was trying to do that
but you moved away before ever they want
to switch it
I wanted this is it's most of them what
do you call this thing better pancake
that's the best part though oh it's the
texture of it I thought I was doing your
fever I know you don't like worms
I'm on vacation I love cars right now
[Music]
it's like I make it into this feel like
a streaker oh is that what's called no
flasher hail is like a trench coat
really a really short trench coat I
should've brought the trench coat I
bought two flash people almost all of my
luggage I only have summer clothes look
at the weather thick that's Paris for
you I even said it last time we were
here you never know what Paris is
whether this is actually colder than
last time
today actually where we lost over here
all this looks like inception the entire
city has a unified look
[Music]
like Mako together that's true just need
to have this going I can do that with
the camera actually
what are we about the we met up to have
dinner with everyone we just got here
and it's funny cuz we came to the same
restaurant last time cuz it's so good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh heaven so they were pointing out to
us from their window and Casey
automatically goes hey and then everyone
in this corner starts looking at us and
like shut up you a typical American I
see some more people all right this is
like the wedding party before the actual
wedding party begins because they're
bringing like all their friends together
but yes majority
Wow good evening
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty much I didn't know they're gonna
be a mall order friends get macaroni
didn't know I was getting some like
brunch go judge me okay
should I fell for the same thing it was
a really really fancy title on the menu
but in the end I just got Turnus it's
really subtle yeah I like it though it's
very creepy like this plate yeah cuz I
recommended this place I'm trying to
save face right now as far as a bomb
macaroni cheese
I keep it real man it's in my name real
but yeah this thing right here that
potatoes duck duck hacci Paris online
alright we're about to visit your guys
is a apartment there's an elevator it's
like three punches stairs
[Music]
Wow
on this no I feel like we transported
into the 20s like the roaring 20s right
now as like watching wall there's a dude
up there that smokes every day they say
me Nicky boy yet I like looking into
people's apartments here because they're
so cute I love it it's like a slice of
life what are we doing now
yeah I'm we're not playing in Berlin and
she's about to arrive lights just got
here so
got on breakfast in the meantime
particulate little Tammy espresso
[Music]
[Music]
here now we are about to do that
[Music]
where are we at
okay so today's the last day of Tour de
France we're coming to dinner to shop
early today where they have a lot of
shops and restaurants and we realized
this is where they closed all the roads
so we get to see a little part of Tour
de France right in front of the Arc de
Triomphe and now I know how to say it
properly okay guys it's a tree oh my god
talk boots we all do - I don't know
welcome to comments or like a hater she
says hi and I'm like chill or it better
[Music]
all right I think for the MVP right here
and for the shot I'm not too sure to get
it but teamwork right
[Music]
so that means we got bored Disneyland's
nuts out we still need Shanghai and Hong
Kong and we been suppose in the world
awesome it's so awesome because it's my
mom and my aunt are here as well so we
get to the Fantasyland with them today
and yeah we're gonna have fun if we're
really tired though but it's really
heavy but it's worth it we are
celebrating someone's birthday
may I say that with the term of
endearment a happy birthday Gina
we're in this time we're with them even
Mary super play Missy
that's like a vocabulary French words
French onion soup Dixon you know what
the funny thing is like I don't
understand a damn thing but if I look at
the menu I know all the food
okay that's all you need at the trip in
France is the food can't take this
jacket of it so we have the same jacket
and everything I have the same jacket
and everything and I think I just a
jacket and everything I know that people
are like why can't they buy different
stuff like this is quality stuff okay
sure we look the same and everything but
I don't care I do care get it up David
around the world look how much bigger
you've got anything to hold you like
this right here
until he's 30 ask him again five minutes
how he's not having to get lower lower
[Music]
[Music]
hey cheers Cheers
[Music]
Karthik you wanna sit what
all right so we got a bus and we're
gonna be going on a bus tour around
Paris and everyone is here or it's not
happy everyone was they gonna make it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cool
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
it's a lot for being said that means a
lot to be in too many things already
people asked me a tip that you guys were
out marriage you're a long way from all
stuff coming out making the way out here
hope you guys are enjoying yourself hope
you guys are enjoying the sights I know
uh repression have done the bus tour by
the first day but ever you know I'm a
different day that's true and because I
know Kevin hey you guys just arrived not
too long ago so that was a nice the bus
tour opener for France for Paris I guess
it's also a good closer for anyone
that's been here for a full week now but
the better closer is tomorrow night
[Applause]
we never dress never dress up as though
we picked Paris to have like a more
high-class - video and to bring everyone
out force everyone are dressed up a
little bit you know change the taste a
little bit and I've had everyone
experience your pian vacation how many
people here is the first time you're in
Europe
[Applause]
but yeah I mean it's our wedding and I
love you very much too
I don't know I'm very speechless when it
comes to another nice yeah if you take
more notes here but I think you like the
food
you like a food of it I promise the next
one you're going to there's any more
kids okay sorry
Hong Kong family thank you for coming
out I haven't seen you guys a long time
for this I know
cheers to Hong Kong family
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for a JK family
very much reporters me and said that we
work with you guys and so it's everyone
here is family to me and then the LA
family aka Leslie email us baby thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]